bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition d' europe hebdo nous sommes à
strasbourg au parlement européen dans
cette émission direction l'italie et
plus précisément turin cet ancien poumon
économique du nord voit aujourd'hui ses
entreprises fermer les unes après les
autres et son taux de chômage grimper
les turinois découvre la grande pauvreté
mais d'abord l'actualité l'ukraine est
il le nouveau champ de bataille de
l'union européenne c'est la question de
la semaine
ils bravent le froid depuis des jours
par centaines par milliers ils campent
sur la place de l'indépendance au centre
de kiev mais pourquoi
car sous la pression de moscou le
président ianoukovitch a suspendu la
signature d'un accord d'association avec
l'union européenne
et s'est rapproché de moscou qui
voudraient voir le pays intégré son
union douanière aïe une volte face qui
réveille les vieux démons de la fracture
ukrainienne l'ouest pro européen contre
l'est russophile des images qui
rappellent sensiblement celle de la
révolution orange en 2004
mais cette fois c'est la violence des
manifestations qui dénote des dizaines
de manifestants blessés et une pression
internationale qui s'accentue
l'europe a dépêché catherine ashton
haute représentante aux affaires
étrangères pour tenter une médiation
en face le camp de moscou où ce le ton
et parle de coup d'état de pogroms et
d'instrumentalisation extérieur tout un
programme
alors l'ukraine nouveaux champs de
bataille européens
et pour évoquer ce difficile dossier
ukrainien celoni de kaiser qui nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau bonjour merci
d'être avec nous bonjour alors vous
connaissez très bien ces questions
internationales quand vous voyez ces
images qui nous rappellent effectivement
la révolution orange de 2004 vous dites
que l'europe a échoué avec le cren
dire que leurs pêchés avec l'ukraine
c'est un peu prématuré d'abord parce que
l'accord n'est pas signé mais ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il ne le sera pas par
exemple au printemps donc qui reste pour
le moment une fenêtre d'opportunité sur
lequel il ya une stratégie qui peut se
déployer vous dire que l'ukraine c'est
pas n'importe quoi c'est une pièce
essentielle du partenariat oriental et
dont on l'a dit elle reste très
russophiles mais elle est en même temps
très européenne alors jusqu'à ce qu'elle
poids est ce qu'il faut choisir jusqu'à
quel point est ce que l'europe peut
demander à l'ukraine de renier par
exemple entre guillemets il à la russie
est ce qu'il faut vraiment que ça se
passe comme ça est-ce qu'on est encore
dans un monde de guerre froide ou est-ce
qu'au contraire il ya des partenariats
qui peuvent se faire sans demander de
renoncer à des elders ces légers
toujours un peu peur moi d'un retour
aujourd'hui à la guerre froide c'est un
petit peu à ça qu'on assiste un
finalement avec cette crème un petit peu
déchiré est-ce que
vous avez peur de d'exactions de la part
du gouvernement le craignent un
coup des jeux bon je peux pas dire que
je
je porte une affection démesurée au
gouvernement ukrainien actuelle et
jusqu'à un certain point on peut dire
que dans cette affaire d' accord
d'association il nous a un peu mener en
bateau parce que je crois qu'il y ait eu
plus de vingt président viktor
ianoukovitch
il ya eu plus de vingt réunions avec lui
avec les autorités européennes et cédera
l affaire était emballé paraphé etc ceci
dit il n'y a pas que lui il ya la russie
qui est effectivement à exercer des
pressions incroyables sur sur l'ukraine
il faut en tenir compte et puis
fondamentalement au delà d'un
attachement qui se voit aujourd'hui dans
les manifestations parce que dans les
manifestants qui viennent à kiev voit
des gens qui portent le drapeau européen
porte le drapeau et c'est assez rapide à
son signal pour ceux qui se demandent
s'ils vont voter en mai 2014 pour nous
européens de même bien de voir des gens
qui sont là avec le drapeau et qui sont
prêtes à voter pour pour lui-même comme
vous voyez
et et on a tort d'en rire parce que ça
traduit ça traduit une
une voyez une aide une adhésion à un
modèle européen qui n'est pas encore
absolument obsolète c'est à dire un
système de valeurs un système de
libertés etc mais au-delà de ça il ya
l'économie et l'économie
c'est peut-être là qu on a failli parce
qu'effectivement ce qu'il faut expliquer
c'est que l'ukraine est dans une
situation économique particulièrement
dramatique en gros leur réserve de
trésorerie permettent la de vivre deux
mois et c'est aussi un peu pour ça que
les appels du pied de la russie ont été
entendus si je puis dire donc qu'est-ce
qu'on avait finalement à offrir aux
ukrainiens pas grand chose face les
ukrainiens veulent se fasse beaucoup
d'ukrainiens dont elle se rapprocher du
corps européen mais pas à n'importe quel
prix pas n'importe quel prix alors pour
le moment que d'une robe rose se
rapprocher d'une europe en crise leur
demandait et leur demanderait des
investissements
de dizaines et de dizaines de milliards
d'euros que pour le moment ils n'ont pas
que l'union européenne n'est pas prête à
l'heure donnée elle peut leur donner un
milliard pas plus de plus
il faut savoir que la plupart de leurs
exportations sont des exportations qui
vont vers la russie et si la russie leur
offre comme elle s'apprête à le faire
une union douanière avec zéro taxe et
c'est à dire la possibilité d'exporter
plus facilement vers ce qu'est leur
marché naturel je dois dire que dans une
situation de crise de pareilles c'est le
règlement vernement ya une certaine
logique nous ne leur avons pas proposé
des choses année là haut qu'on appelle
des pro actifs par rapport à ça et aussi
dit ils veulent tellement arrivée en
europe ma foi on va leur offrir là
l'idée c'était de les intégrer à terme
quand on est dans un partenariat
privilégié comme ça c'est on réfléchit à
quoi à l'élargissement parce que
finalement vous êtes en train de nous
expliquer que c'est un petit peu
l'ukraine est là est la fille aînée de
la russie si je puis dire donc est-ce
que c'est pas anti naturel c'est pas
aussi naturel de les intégrer dans une
politique de voisinage ce sont le voisin
n'est sûr après tout donc dans la
politique de voisinage c'est à dire avec
des accords privilégiés avec des taux
préférentiels et ses draps et aidera
d'appliquer la règle en usinage au
niveau orientale c'est absolument
naturel ce qui n'est peut-être pas
naturel c'est que a small est un
arrachement qu'ils se fassent on est les
voisins en général de deux côtés à la
fois je veux dire j'habite une maison
j'ai un voisin de droite j'ai un voisin
de gauche est-ce que je suis obligé pour
ça de choisir un nom si je ne demande
pas d'être nombre de l'union or relève
est donc
tout tout tout tout est là dans est-ce
que l'ukraine va vouloir adhérer à
l'union européenne alors cinq ans qu'il
ya clairement déterminé son choix c'est
celui de ioulia timochenko qui est
l'opposant historique à viktor
ianoukovitch qui est actuellement en
prison et on a vu beaucoup sa fille
prendre la parole en son nom en tribune
je souhaiterais qu'on les écoute
yann en l'échangé seule la force du
peuple ukrainien peut stopper
ianoukovitch il ne comprend qu'un seul
langage celui de la force tranquille et
c'est de cette manière dont nous devons
nous adresser à lui nous devons dans la
paix et en toute légalité les amener à
la table des négociations
est ce qu'on peut espérer de la part de
viktor ianoukovitch un fléchissement de
sa part on peut espérer très fortement
si un dialogue avec l'opposition et on
peut espérer raisonnablement si les
négociations se passent bien a pas
l'écho des négociations qui ont eu lieu
hier avec la kth tonnes très
certainement qui va aller dans la voie
de l'apaisement qui ne va pas demander
de décision immédiate qui va dire prenez
votre temps mais il est possible de
remettre l'ouvragé sur la table je crois
qu'on bloque dit ne sera qu il faut
absolument décrisper parce que pour le
moment on a eu un jeu politique avec
tous les partis de l'opposition dont
celui du parti de timochenko mais aussi
celui de klitschko ce
boxeur très très imposant et aidera mais
on voit bien que
derrière ce côté là il ya un règlement
de comptes entre l'opposition et le
président ukrainien pour le moment mais
donc tout ça peut se régler si ce n'est
pas trop politisé mais en tout cas nos
rapports avec l'ukraine moi je ne me
déclare je ne déclare pas forfait
aujourd'hui alors il ya un autre une
autre question internationale qui vous
occupe beaucoup en ce moment c'est la
question de la centrafrique les l'armée
française est engagée depuis quelques
jours maintenant on entend finalement
assez peu le parlement européen et plus
largement l'europe sur cette question
est ce qu'on peut espérer quelque chose
dans les prochains jours on peut espérer
en tout cas une résolution demain vous
allez me dire qu'une résolution cépages
hirondelles qui fait le printemps avec
une hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps
non plus mais donc c'est déjà quelque
chose va dire que depuis près d'un an
de manière récurrente la commissaire
georges isaac et la commissaire à l'aide
humanitaire et tout son staff vienne au
parlement européen nous dire il y a pour
le moment un génocide qui se prépare en
centrafrique cet affreux et personne ne
bouge on parle beaucoup de la syrie et
c'est un problème brûlant politiquement
mais aujourd'hui on a tous le scénario
d'un génocide en afrique et donc quand
une fois de plus l'europe a été
attentiste le allocution international
envoyer de l'aide humanitaire l'europe a
envoyé ce qu'elle peut mais l'europe n'a
pas l'air mais il faut une force armée
là bas entouré une force de maintien de
la paix il faut pour le moment une
action politique sorte il faut l'embargo
sur les armes convient enfin de décider
après un an au conseil de sécurité on a
eu le 5 décembre une résolution qui est
très complet 14 pages sur la
centrafrique et moi je voudrais dire
quelque chose j'entends beaucoup le tout
et son contraire par rapport à l'action
française je voudrais dire que tantôt
malik en centrafrique on me dit oui mais
il avait des intérêts là-bas écouter la
france a peut être des intérêts au mali
et l'a peut-être des intérêts en
centrafrique mais en tout cas ce que je
peux garantir c'est que les maliens et
les centrafricains sont venus nous
trouver depuis un an déjà les maliens
l'avait fait pendant un an sans qu'il
n'y ait quoi que ce soit qui bouge et si
quelqu'un peut bouger eux j'en suis je
mais c'est la france ça pourrait être un
hobby mais que la france laisse les
faits je ne respecte profondément ma
dans ce qu'il faut c'est renforcer
effectivement cette action française qui
a pris un peu les devants par rapport à
l'onu mais il faut absolument intervenir
sur tous les plans sur le plan monétaire
sur le plan politique sur le plan du
maintien de la paix en afrique centrale
parce que sinon ce serait vraiment un
crime de plus que nous commettrions n'a
pas écouté merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous et d'avoir évoqué ces
questions nous on continue on disait à
l'instant l'europe est en crise et s'il
ya un pays qui le vit particulièrement
en ce moment c'est l'italie nous avons
été à turin ce poumon économique du nord
de l'italie tu découvres l'anneau
évaporé retard cette nouvelle pauvreté
des visages que me connaissaient pas
rencontre c'est un reportage de françois
goulard
on a pas que tiken alors vous allez
devoir attendre
voilà des mois qu'alexandra observe
cette file qui s'allonge devant la soupe
populaire sacro cuore dj zone au milieu
des réfugiés syriens un chef
d'entreprise une professeure de
sociologie
c'est le visage de la nouvelle pauvreté
qui frappe sans distinction toutes les
catégories sociales
avant les italiens convoyer c'était des
clochards dans la rue depuis toujours
mais depuis trois ans on voit arriver
des gens instruits les chefs de famille
on a eu un ancien psychologue par
exemple ou des entrepreneurs qui ont
fait faillite
ici aussi il y as foule devant caritas
le secours catholique italien dans ce
quartier populaire est installé leurs
centres d coûte un endroit où se
pressent ceux qui n'ont plus rien
c'est seul oui et je vous ai amené cette
amende que je ne peux pas payer j'espère
qu'ils ne vont pas me couper le gaz
la signora janet taux est invalide à 67%
mais pour toucher l'aide de l'état elle
doit être invalide à 75% elle n'a donc
aucune ressource et doit faire face
seule à la maladie
je viens ici parce que j'ai besoin dead
dead économique et morale n'importe quoi
qu'ils puissent m'aider j'ai un cancer
alors je ne peux plus travailler donc je
ne peux plus payer le loyer de mon
logement social et j'ai peur de perdre
ma maison la case la case
elle repartira avec un sac de provisions
dès sa facture de gaz régler mon panneau
qui masque un caennais ici on est un peu
leur dernier recours
ils viennent après avoir fait le tour
des services sociaux parfois ils ont
déjà écrit au maire au président de la
république
du rhin la prospère autrefois pôles
industriels de premier plan et bastion
de la fiat aujourd'hui ville la plus
pauvre du nord de la péninsule
les télévisions italiennes viennent d'y
filmer la misère comme elle le faisait
il ya peu encore dans les pouilles
votre frigo est vide
oui j'ai débranché j'ai une cuisine plus
parce que je ne peux plus payer gazon
peu plus
la fiat a délocalisé ses sous traitants
ferment les uns après les autres 600
entreprises ont mis la clé sous la porte
en 2012 le chômage a été multiplié par
deux en cinq ans aujourd'hui une
personne sur dix vit en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté maintenant on attaque on a
comme promis à durenque une ville avec
un passé manufacturier qui a été frappé
de plein fouet par la crise comme tous
les centres urbains et en tant que
grande ville elle a tendance à attirer
les pauvres parce qu'elle leur donne
plus d'opportunités
les familles de la classe moyenne
veulent à tout prix maintenir leur
niveau de vie elle pioche dans leur
épargne mais elles finissent par
s'endetter aujourd'hui ces familles
s'endettent pour survivre
survivre l'activité principale qui guide
les journées de sonia
l'appartement lui a été prêté en urgence
par caritas elle vient d'être expulsé du
sien
voilà la chambre je dors ici avec ma
fille asia
et voilà la cuisine et monfils ricky il
dort ici sur le canapé
cette ancienne commerçante a tout perdu
son magasin son logement suite aux
nouvelles taxes imposées par le
gouvernement et ses plans d'austérité
successifs sonia doit aujourd'hui
composer avec 500 euros par mois
il a fallu couper dans tout on ne
pouvait même plus permettre d'acheter
une glace à 2 euros
c'est arrivé plus d'une fois de ne plus
pouvoir acheter à manger et que les
enfants rentrent et me disent maman le
frigo est encore vide c'est vrai
les caisses de la ville aussi sont vides
et pour éviter la faillite turin brade
son patrimoine cette ancienne caserne de
pompiers par exemple est vendu 4
millions d'euros
l'ailé gauche de la coalition municipale
elle n'a arraché qu'un million d'euros
pour lutter contre les expulsions et
pour cet élu les problèmes d'argent de
la ville ont un coupable tout désigné
elles partent au destin mais l'état
c'est la faute du pacte de stabilité
européen depuis 2008 les communes
italiennes doivent respecter les
équilibres budgétaires m elles doivent
aussi rendre à l'état 60 80 millions
d'euros s'il n'y a pas de politique
sociale nationale ni de politique du
travail la crise est bien ne s'arrêtera
pas là vers
la crise et
3000 familles ont été expulsées de leur
logement l'année dernière faute de payer
leur loyer l'église et les associations
se retrouve bien seul dans ce combat
contre la pauvreté dans le pays
dix millions de personnes vivent avec
moins de 990 euros par mois et par foyer
et voilà pour ce reportage tourné à
turin par françois gaulin mesdames
patricia toya vous êtes vice présidente
du groupe socialiste et démocrate et
donc députés italienne il avait tenu un
charretier vous êtes députée française
membre du groupe ppe qu'est ce que cela
vous inspire de voir cette nouvelle
pauvreté en italie jamais on aurait pu
croire que le poumon économique donc le
nord de l'italie aurait pu un jour se
retrouver dans cette dans cet état là
patricia toi ya là un effet je pense je
m'excuse d'abord pour mon enfance et je
vous aurais pas
très beau mais je pense qu'on peut
également grâce aux fondamentaux non je
pense qu'ils en effet je vive honour
devise habile à nos la lombalgie c'est
tout près de pleymo de la région de
touraine cédric dans notre région nos
régions il y avait beaucoup de zine
beaucoup d'activités dans le passé et
donc ne connaissons pas trop de chômage
de pauvreté parce qu'ils avaient aussi
pauvreté très
pas si grave dans le passé parce qu'il
avait beaucoup d'occasions de travail la
difficulté c'est vrai qu'il ya des
politiques européennes qui empêche la
croissance parce qu'il avait porté des
politiques d'austérité et roa dans une
seule sans réduire les déficits du coup
les déficits et ne pas être attractif à
la croissance et si on réduit les
déficits et on n'a pas de cohésion
sociale il ya une avril des politiques
sociales et politiques sociales en
italie on a découvert qu'il n'y avait
pas de mouvement il ya beaucoup des
politiques sociales qui ont été réduites
dans ces dernières années à cause de la
politique d'austérité est-ce que
même en chantier est-ce qu'il faut
arrêter l'austérité
il faut faire très attention il faut
juguler ces politiques d'austérité
moi je suis pour le rétablissement des
équilibres budgétaires parce qu'on ne
peut pas continuer à courir après un
endettement nationale comme ça mais ce
que je critique c'est que l'on fasse
payer porter ce rétablissement de
l'équilibré budgétaire à des individus
alors qu'il faut commencer par réduire
le train de vie de l'état et la dépense
publique c'est ça le premier levier le
deuxième point et qu'on voit très bien
dans ce dans ce reportage qui est qui
est très touchant c'est que aujourd'hui
il faut que l'europe soit une europe
solidaire une europe fraternelle sur le
plan humain pourquoi parce que dans le
problème de la crise on a imposé la
solidarité économique la solidarité
bancaire
la solidarité financière
mais la solidarité sociale il a fallu
qu'on se bat avec les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui pensaient que à chacun
ses pauvres eh bien non une des valeurs
fondatrices de l'europe c'est la
solidarité et c'est un peu ce qu'on
reproche à l'europe ce qu'elle manque
enfin cette europe qui a voulu la paix
qui était censé être protectrice fin à
l'origine aujourd'hui est plutôt
destructrice pour les peuples c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me suis battu
pour que nous conservions le fond des de
plus des murs et que la distribution
alimentaire par exemple que l'on voit
dans ce reportage soit adossée à des
politiques européennes mais non
seulement les chefs d'état voulait le
supprimer non seulement il a fallu se
battre pour le conserver mais en plus il
a fallu se battre une deuxième fois pour
le rétablir à sa hauteur de 3 milliards
500 millions bon et puis et puis le
fonds social européen il a fallu aussi
se battre pourquoi parce que je propose
est que ce fonds social soient
sanctuarisés soit préservée à hauteur de
25 % des fonds de cohésion la fin
c'était la bataille la bataille de la
commission
mais bien sûr c'était une vraie bataille
et puis là encore les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ne voulait pas et tout ça
il faut qu'on arrive à le préserver en
quatrième point on a voulu aussi que
dans le fond social européen lee et 20 %
du fonds social européen qui soit
justement patricia consacré à
l'intégration professionnelle des plus
pauvres et des plus démunis c'est à dire
des publics des plus fragiles une fille
dans ce temps là ils voulaient nous
mettre une clause de
déquilibre financiers c'est à dire que
s'il n'y avait pas la clause de
conditionnalité s'appelle mais c'est pas
grave c'est à dire que un budget d'état
en déséquilibre entraîné une privation
du fonds social européen mais non mais
ça ça s'appelle la double peine bien sûr
ces autos faire attention parce que
quand on voit qu'on réduit la dépense
pour la santé pour les services sociaux
pour le travail pour les femmes qui sont
des valides on avait cette femme est
valide à l'ordre je ne crois pas à cette
réduction on doit réduire la dépense pas
utile pour le progrès des ja est une
autre chose encore le pacte de stabilité
pour les municipalités qu'est-ce qu'on a
une conséquence la conséquence qui aussi
sur une musicalité dans son budget de la
chambre pour faire des travaux pour
faire par exemple les écoles à des
travaux heureuse les investissements sur
les dépenses courantes on ne peut pas
les faire pour le problème des parcs de
stabilité que l'on doit pas s'il s'agit
de travaux et productive mais limpide on
cherche du travail
moi je voulais insister sur trois points
le premier c'est que très souvent on dit
l'europe c'est le premier la preuve le
plus haut niveau de vie moyen au monde
oui mais il ya des écarts et aujourd'hui
il y à 19 millions d'européens qui ne
mangent pas un repas avec des protéines
tous les rites d'un jour c'est donc
terrine il ya des écarts terrible à
réduire et cette fraternité entre les
peuples européens elle doit vraiment
exister parce que si on veut faire aimer
l'europe par les peuples par les
citoyens on voit bien qu'il faut donner
aux citoyens il faut que l'europe les
protège effectivement le deuxième point
c'est que la crise a considérablement
aggravé cette situation de pauvreté en
particulier les femmes sont sorties du
travail mais il n'y a plus aucune
sociale les jeunes en particulier dans
certaines régions
210 40 % des 15 30 ans qui sont au
chômage par exemple oui des 15 25 ans
qui sont au chômage si vous prenez la
tranche 15 30 ans os x
2 le nombre de bénéficiaires des
politiques européennes donc vous voyez
qu'on a moulé encore entre 25 et 30 ans
deux jeunes qui sont à la recherche d'un
emploi donc on a une vraie pauvreté qui
se développent chez les femmes chez les
jets les jeunes chez les publics les
plus sensibles troisièmement
nous avons des épiceries sociales
aujourd'hui dans les universités
c'est à dire que qu'est ce qu'il ya de
plus important que la formation pour
pouvoir intégrer le monde professionnel
et quelle est la meilleure garantie
contre la pauvreté que l'insertion
professionnelle et on voit les acteurs y
pointe est justement d des fonds de
fonds social européen vers l'insertion
professionnelle activement pour nous
c'est essentiel
l'intégration professionnelle est le
premier levier de l'intégration sociale
alors justement à ce propos il y à le
conseiller municipal que l'on voit dans
ce reportage qui avait une question à
vous poser en direct on les écoute
ok je crois que l'europe a besoin
d'amortisseur social pour cette crise et
je vous demande selon vous si c'est
possible d'imaginer un revenu européen
de citoyenne
est ce qu'on peut espérer un jour avoir
un revenu de la sorte
on a demandé dans les solutions du
parlement d'avoir cet événement il ya
différentes moyen de l'entendre a
peut-être revenir peut-être minimum et
un salaire il ya des différents modèles
il ya aussi des pays européens la
plupart qui a quelque chose qui
ressemble à une revenir dessus je pense
qu'on peut le faire
ce sera au lieu d autres amortisseur
social qu'elle soit en plus mais je
pense que c'est une bonne question pour
faire sortir de la pauvreté il ya des
petits enfants qui vivent dans la
pauvreté c'est pas correct c'est pas
possible d'accepter à mon avis d'un mot
concession politique c'est pas possible
d'arrêter ça donc c'est bien et même
temps passé par une venue pour maintenir
les gens dans cette dépendance de
revenir peut-être pour faire sortir de
la pauvreté pour faire vivre d'une
situation descente on peut dire des
centres moyenne mais dit d'unités mais
en même temps pour donner des
instruments ont des possibilités d'avoir
un travail d'être autosuffisant tirent
en fait dessus est ce qu'on peut
imaginer un dispositif de la sorte est
ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
pourriez porter c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut porter mais je ne veux pas
vendre un rêve impossible
c'est à dire que je ne le connais pas
sur moi pour dire demain il va y avoir
un revenu minimum européen aligné sur
l'ensemble des pays d'europe parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a encore patricia tu
le sais trop d'écart de niveau de vie
entre un certain nombre
d'exemples
va falloir procéder par paliers par
étapes et peut-être par branche par
secteurs de telle sorte que l'on puisse
construire la convergence en tous les
cas moi je le défends cette construction
d'europe sociale du travail chaque jour
on voit bien aussi qu'avec la nouvelle
directive que nous portons tous ensemble
sur le détachement des travailleurs qui
élit qui pose de jouer sur ces
différences de niveau de vie entre entre
les états parce que jouer entre les
différences de niveau 10 c'est ancré la
pauvreté et moi c'est parce que je veux
faire je veux au contraire construire
cette convergence sociale pour que l'on
sorte de la pauvreté un certain nombre
de bien écouter on continuera dessus ce
dossier merci madame cette émission est
malheureusement terminée mais on
continuera ce débat merci d'avoir été
avec nous pour nous c'est terminé cette
semaine rendez vous la semaine prochaine
à bruxelles avec ahmed tazir bonne suite
de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires